-Well, here's what
people are talking about.
Today was the big
Alabama Senate election,
and as promised, Roy Moore
rode his horse to the polls.
[ Laughter ]
It got weird when people said,
"Can we vote for the horse?"
And they go, "No, no,
he's riding the horse."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
So he rode the horse in.
And get this -- the horse that
Moore rode was named Sassy.
[ Laughter ]
What doesn't say "I'm innocent"
like a 70-year-old man
riding a horse name Sassy?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"You girls wanna see a horse?
You wanna meet Sassy?"
[ Laughter ]
Everybody's talking about this.
Last night, Roy Moore's wife
tried to defend him
against bigotry claims
by saying,
"One of our attorneys is a Jew."
[ Audience groans ]
So, happy first night of
Hanukkah, everyone, eh?
Isn't that great?
Happy Hanukkah!
Wow.
Another speaker told a story
about how Moore
once left a brothel
because he thought
the girls looked too young.
[ Audience groans, laughter ]
You know things are bad when
even the good stories about you
involve prostitution.
It's like, "I would never!
I have standards!"
[ Laughter ]
-Indeed!
-"No w-a-a-ay!"
[ Laughter ]
"Come on, Sassy, let's go!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Off to the American Girl
doll store."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ew.
-Oh-ho!
-Listen to this, guys.
I read that Vladimir Putin gets
daily reports of Trump's tweets.
[ Laughter ]
Every day,
Putin reads them and goes,
"My God.
What have I done?"
What have I --
Oh, my goodness."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Speaking of tweets,
trump got in a twitter fight
with Senator Kirsten Gillibrand
over his
sexual assault allegations.
Yeah, just this week,
he insulted a senator,
endorsed Roy Moore,
and called 20 women liars.
It's like he saw
his approval rating was 32
and said, "I bet I can get it
under 30 by the weekend.
Just give me a --
Give me a tweet!
Give me something to tweet on!
Come on, Sassy!
Come here, girl!"
[ Laughter ]
-[ Whinnies ]
-Taught the horse to tweet.
[ Laughter ]
Check this out --
"Star Wars: The Last Jedi"
is expected to make over
$425 million by Sunday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can tell
they're making a lot of money,
'cause today, Yoda endorsed
the Republican tax plan.
-Really?
-Yeah. "It's great."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is kind of crazy.
I read that people are actually
taking out mortgages
to buy Bitcoin...
[ Light laughter ]
...because they think
it's such a solid investment.
Then they put on
their Sketcher Shape-Ups
and went out to buy
some Dippin' Dots.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
"The pounds are melting off!
Pounds are melting off.
Hold on a second.
The Dots are great.
No one can even tell
I'm wearing these."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm losing so much weight.
You don't even know who this is?
It's me.
I just lost a lot of weight."
[ Laughter ]
No, you didn't, that's a scam.
All right.
Oh, finally, this made me laugh.
Did you see this
"Jeopardy!" contestant?
-Yeah.
-A "Jeopardy!" contestant
last night
was very, very aggressive
when it came
to using his clicker to buzz in.
You won't even --
He's the guy on the left,
like you need to know,
but watch.
Check this out.
-LaKedra.
-What is the Shih Tzu?
-Charlie.
-What is Wales?
-LaKedra.
-Who is Thumper?
-What is Monticello?
-Charlie.
-Who is Frank Lloyd Wright?
-LaKedra.
-Who is Betsy Ross?
-What is Hokkaido?
[ Laughter ]
-Charlie.
-What is The Great Pumpkin?
-What are
the Great Smoky Mountains?
-Lakedra.
-What is folic acid?
-Charlie?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Can you give me a little
clicky click?
[ Clicking ]
LaKedra.
What is too much Red Bull?
[ Laughter ]
[ Clicking ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
But he --
Poor Ben. Ben, yeah.
He finally got called on.
Let's that a look
at how that went.
-Ben.
-Who is Data?
-No.
-There you go.
[ Rimshot ]
-Hey-oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right -- he finished with
zero dollars and carpal tunnel.
There you go, everybody.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!